sixteen states here in the US have
joined a brief an amicus brief filed
with the US Supreme Court arguing that
their states the employers in their
states should be allowed to fire people
if they're LGBTQ sixteen different
states their attorneys general are
writing the Supreme Court because of a
case the court may or may not take up
saying that we also want to be able and
think it should be perfectly legal and
it's certainly not against the civil
rights act to fire somebody simply for
being LGBTQ and their argument is that
because sex in the Civil Rights Act two
sixty four they're trying to argue that
that only refers to your sex at birth
it doesn't include sexual orientation it
doesn't include you know any kind of
transgendered nothing just what you are
at birth and it doesn't go any further
beyond that at all whatsoever they want
to take us back back in time and
essentially criminalize homosexuality
anyone any member of the LGBTQ community
would be able to be fired from their
employer just because of who they are as
a person that's what these states want
here the states Alabama Arkansas Kansas
Kentucky Louisiana Maine Mississippi
Nebraska Oklahoma South Carolina South
Dakota Tennessee Texas Utah West
Virginia and Wyoming every one of those
states wants to be able to fire people
just for who they are we have to take a
break we'll be right back